So in the late 1980s, Broward County Sheriff's Office decided that they just didn't have
enough crack cocaine to use and undercover stings.
So what was their solution?
They set up shop on the 7th floor of the Broward County Courthouse in Fort Lauderdale,
where they cooked crack using $20,000 worth of seized cocaine.
They made crack rocks, packaged them individually, and then sold them to people during sting operations.
At the time, those who were involved defended the practice, claiming it was efficient for
making a rest and save time on lab tests.
However, however, called it outrageous and unethical, defense attorneys were especially vocal,
pointing out the moral issues of cops creating and distributing crack.
Come on now.
The story even shocked federal officials with some admitting that they had never heard of such practice before.
Let's fast forward to today.
And the fallout from the scheme is finally being addressed.
Broward County State Attorney Harold F. Pire announced that his office is working to vacate
as many as 2,600 convictions tied to these particular operations.
Many of these convictions involve people who were not selling drugs but buying small amounts,
often within 1,000 feet of schools which carried harsher penalties.
The Florida Supreme Court, though, ruled in 1993 that the actions violated the state's
due process clause, declaring an unconstitutional to charge people in cases where the drugs were
manufactured and sold by police officers.
And layman's turns, it's wrong for police departments to make crack and sell it to people
in order to lock them up.